Kafka and RabbitMQ aren't
interchangeable. They solve different
problems, and picking the wrong one can
mean significant rework later. But both
exist to solve the same fundamental
challenge, though. When one service
needs to talk to another, the simplest
option is a direct call. Your order
service makes an HTTP request to your
inventory service, waits for a response,
and moves on.
This works great until that inventory
service is slow, or down, or getting
hammered with traffic. Suddenly, your
order service is just stuck waiting,
timing out, or dropping requests on the
floor because it has nowhere to put
them. Message queues like Kafka and
RabbitMQ solve this because they add a
buffer between your services.
Instead of calling the inventory service
directly, your order service drops a
message into a queue, and then just
returns immediately. The inventory
service can then pick up that message
whenever it's ready and process it.
If the inventory service is slow,
messages accumulate in the queue.
If you get a massive spike in orders
during a flash sale, for example, the
queue absorbs all of that traffic, and
then lets your downstream services
process it at whatever pace they can
handle. So, Kafka and RabbitMQ both give
you this decoupling. Producers,
consumers, with a broker or a message
queue in the middle. But how they
actually work under the hood is
fundamentally different, and that's what
needs to end up driving your
decision-making when you're deciding
which of the two to use in your project.
Starting with RabbitMQ,
RabbitMQ is a traditional message
broker, and it follows a mental model
that most developers find pretty
intuitive if you've ever used a
queue-like data structure.
A producer sends a message to a broker.
The broker looks at some routing rules
you've configured to figure out which
queue that message belongs to, and then
a consumer pulls the messages off of
that queue.
Once the consumer acknowledges
successful processing, RabbitMQ deletes
the message.
The broker handles a lot for you. It
routes messages to the right queues,
tracks which messages have been
delivered, and then it retries any
failed deliveries.
When a message fails repeatedly,
RabbitMQ moves it to a dead letter queue
automatically so that you can debug it
later. As the engineer, you configure
these rules, and then the broker
enforces them.
Kafka doesn't have all of this built in.
If you need dead letter handling in
Kafka, you end up building it yourself.
Now, from the perspective of the
consumer, this is simple. You connect or
subscribe to a queue, messages show up,
you process them, and you send back an
acknowledgement. All of the complexity
of figuring out where messages came
from, where they need to go, that's the
broker's problem, not the consumers.
This model maps really well to
task-oriented workloads. Sending emails,
processing payments, resizing messages.
You've got a unit of work that needs to
happen. You drop it into a queue,
something picks it up and does it. As we
alluded to, Kafka works a little
differently. Instead of being a message
broker that routes messages to queues
and deletes them when they're consumed,
Kafka is essentially a distributed
append-only log.
When a producer sends a message, Kafka
appends it to a topic.
That message doesn't disappear when
someone reads it. It just sits there in
the log. And depending on how you've
configured your attention, it may stay
there for hours, days, weeks, or even
indefinitely.
Consumers then read from this log, but
they're responsible for tracking their
own position.
Kafka calls this position an offset.
So, when your consumer reads a message
number 500, your consumer then remembers
that it's at position 500. If your
consumer crashes or restarts, it looks
up where it left off, and it picks up
from there.
And if you need to reread a message from
an hour ago, you just rewind at that
offset. Totally possible.
That changes the model.
RabbitMQ is a smart broker with simple
consumers. It handles routing, tracks
deliveries, manages retries.
Kafka is a simple broker with smart
consumers. It stores messages in order.
Consumers decide what to read and when.
Kafka does track consumer group offsets,
but the consumer drives the logic still.
The benefit is that messages become
durable and replayable in Kafka.
So, multiple consumer groups can read
the same stream independently. Your
analytics team can process the same
events as your real-time notification
system. A new service that comes online
6 months from now can read the entire
history from day one and do whatever
backfilling it needs to do. So, let's
emphasize that distinction again.
RabbitMQ is a message broker. Messages
just flow through it.
Kafka is a log. Messages live in it.
In RabbitMQ, once a message is consumed,
it's gone. In Kafka, messages persist
and any number of consumers can read
them at any time from any point in
history.
This one difference drives almost every
other trade-off.
Because they solve different problems,
many teams end up actually using both.
Kafka as their durable event stream that
multiple systems read from, RabbitMQ as
the task queue that processes the work
that those events trigger. Now that you
understand the basic models, here are
the specific technical differences that
should drive your decision.
Starting with ordering guarantees.
Both systems preserve order, but
differently. RabbitMQ queues are
strictly ordered, meaning messages come
out in the order that they went in. So,
if you had just a single consumer, then
you are guaranteed perfect ordering. But
with multiple consumers pulling from the
queue at the same time, they each
process in parallel. So, you could trade
off that ordering for throughput.
Kafka, on the other hand, splits each
topic into partitions.
So, order is guaranteed only within a
partition, but not across partitions.
You control which partition a message
goes to by its partition key.
All orders for consumer 12345 go to the
same partition and get processed in
order. Customer 67890's orders may go to
a different partition.
So, each consumer's orders stay in
sequence, but there is no global
ordering.
The trade-off is that RabbitMQ gives you
global ordering with a single consumer.
Kafka gives you per entity ordering with
parallelism. Pick based on which one you
need. This decision then has a
consequence on throughput and latency.
RabbitMQ handles about 4,000 to 10,000
messages per second. Of course, this is
dependent on message size and hardware.
But the latency sits at around 1 to 5
milliseconds for low-volume workloads.
That's because the broker pushes
messages to consumers automatically, but
the broker's also doing a lot of work.
Tracking delivery state, managing
acknowledgements, handling routing
decisions, all of that per message
overhead ends up adding up, and as it
increases, throughput decreases.
Kafka handles over a million messages
per second, roughly 100 times more.
Latency is higher at baseline, typically
5 to 50 milliseconds, because consumers
pull messages in batches, rather than
receiving them immediately.
The broker does far less work per
message. It appends to a sequential log,
and then lets consumers track their own
position.
And so, under heavy load, that
simplicity really pays off. All that it
needs to do is append to a log, and thus
latency can stay consistent even as the
volume grows. What about delivery
guarantees, which is a really, really
important topic when it comes to message
queues?
What happens when a consumer fails to
process a message?
You have two options. You could lose
that message, or you could deliver it
again to another consumer and risk
duplicating the work.
At most once delivery means that you
might lose messages. The broker sends
once and it doesn't retry.
This is really fast, but if something
goes wrong, the message is gone forever.
At least once means that you might get
duplicates. The broker will just retry
until it gets an acknowledgement from a
consumer. This way you get no data loss,
but your consumers could end up seeing
that message twice and thus processing
it twice.
Both RabbitMQ and Kafka support at least
once, which is what most applications
need and is the industry standard. Kafka
does also support exactly once, which is
the holy grail, where each message is
passed and processed exactly one time.
But it's much more limited than it
sounds, So, be cautious if anybody
recommends this.
It only works when both input and output
are Kafka topics within the exact same
Kafka cluster under Kafka transactions.
So, the moment you need to write to a
database, call on an external API, or
cross cluster boundaries, you're back to
at least once. In practice, most
applications still need item potent
consumers. So, don't end up picking
Kafka just because you heard it supports
exactly once. The reality is it's a lot
more nuanced than that, and for your use
case, it probably doesn't. RabbitMQ is
much simpler to run. It's a single
binary. It's straightforward clustering.
It has built-in management UI. So, if
you're a small team running just a few
queues, it's really approachable.
Kafka is, of course, harder.
Historically, you needed Zookeeper as a
separate coordination service. Newer
versions don't use that, they use Raft,
uh which eliminates the need for
Zookeeper, but you still need to manage
partition rebalancing, broker failures,
topic configurations, and consumer group
coordination. So, there's a lot more to
learn, and a lot more that can go wrong.
Managed services change this calculus,
of course. You have Confluent Cloud,
Amazon MSK, and Azure Event Hubs, which
handle most of that Kafka complexity for
you. So, if you're choosing Kafka,
strongly consider a managed service
unless you have dedicated infrastructure
expertise already within the team. So,
to wrap up here, when should you use
each? You'll want RabbitMQ if you need
task queues and background jobs, like
sending emails, processing payments,
resizing images. The work goes in, it
gets done, and the message disappears.
If you want smart routing, like the
broker decides which worker gets which
message based on content.
If you want low latency at moderate
scale, so sub 5 ms delivery when you're
not pushing millions of messages. And
you want simple operations. It's easier
to set up, and it's easier to reason
about.
Instagram actually uses RabbitMQ to
process photo uploads. When you post a
picture, resizing and filtering happens
via background workers, which are pulled
off of RabbitMQ queues. Reddit, as I
understand it, also uses it to build
comment threads and calculate karma
scores. So, these are classic task queue
patterns. On the other hand, you'll want
Kafka if you need multiple systems
reading the same events, analytics,
fraud detection, billing, and audit
logging, all consuming one stream
independently.
If you need replay capabilities,
reprocessing historical data to debug
issues or rebuild state.
If you have massive scale, millions of
events per second with consistent
latency requirements.
And if you need a durable event history,
so a permanent record of everything that
ever happened.
Netflix processes petabytes of data
daily through Kafka for recommendations
and billing. Uber uses it for real-time
pricing and fraud detection across
millions of rides. And then LinkedIn
invented Kafka and still uses it to
power their feed and messaging. So,
these systems need every event stored,
and need to be replayable, and are
consumed by dozens of different
services. So, if you have a well-defined
constrained use case that fits the
RabbitMQ model, like a task queue or
background jobs, go with RabbitMQ for
its simplicity. For everything else, you
may need to lean towards Kafka and
consider whether or not you want to host
your own or just use a managed service.
Or, of course, you can use both. Kafka
is the event backbone, RabbitMQ for the
background jobs that those events
trigger.